Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this will be
my new Captain America 4 video they just released
another first look and they changed the title
it's now going to be Brave New World instead
of New World Order I'll explain why they did that
there is still the same meaning behind the title
as it was before but there were a couple important
reasons why they wanted to change the title they
also released a first look at Harrison Ford and
Sam Wilson's Captain America meeting each other
behind the monitor so I'll explain what's going
on with them during the movie too and what's on
the monitors behind them if you're brand new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos they're going to be releasing the movie
around this time next year so we won't have to
wait that long to get the next big trailer they do
have Comic-Con coming next week Vincent D'Onofrio
already said they're gonna have a big Daredevil
Born Again panel so there'll be a bunch more
trailers that they'll release there and a bunch
more teasers and plans about what's happening
the next couple of years with Avengers 5 Kang
Dynasty Avengers 6 Secret Wars and everything
else in Marvel phase six but if you look at
the picture here you see Sam Wilson in his new
costume like they wanted to show an official look
at his costume because one leaked a couple weeks
ago I did a video about that because it was kind
of a janky potato quality picture this is meant
to be a nice shiny look at what his costume looks
like it's meant to be more of a stealth evolution
of his last costume like his last costume that
he just got in Falcon and Winter Soldier mixed
with Captain America's newer suit from Avengers
end game his brand new wings are still made of
vibranium if you look at the monitor on the upper
right here you can see that part of its deploy
they're using it for some special effects
reference like it looks like he's wearing a
different suit but it's meant to be the same suit
it just looks a little bit different because he's
wearing a special piece on top that they use in
special effects when they're in post-production
to finish it so that it's a little bit easier for
them to finish the scene with him using his wings
like that you also notice that Harrison Ford is
sitting there watching the playback and he's just
wearing a regular t-shirt the reason why he's
not wearing any special clothes is because most
of his role is actually motion capture for the
most part when Robert Downey Jr was making all
the Avengers movies all the previous Iron Man
movies he just walked around with dots on his
face there are scenes early here in the movie
when they're at that funeral where he's wearing
a normal suit but I think most of the movie he
is supposed to be red Hulk the monitor that's
right in front of him on the left side is just
some foliage like some plant life they're meant
to be on tiamat's body one of the biggest plot
points in the movie is meant to be them racing
to grab all the resources on tiamat's body
before the other world Nations do the actual
title Brave New World is taken both from William
Shakespeare's Tempest in adel's huxley's novel
by the same name and during the plot of that book
the world turns into something more akin to what
Hydra had planned for the world during Captain
America Winter Soldier the original title New
World Order had a deeper meaning that connected
to that during that movie arnim Zola talks about
hydra's grand plan saying that their new world
order is about to begin purification process is
complete hydra's New World Order that's what the
movie titled Captain America New World Order means
the serpent Society with Sharon Carter herself Val
Thunderbolt Ross Red Hulk are basically trying to
take over create an New World Order so the movie
will have a very Winter Soldier type of vibe with
all this crazy red Hulk stuff going on in this
adamantium stuff probably the main reason why
they changed the title from New World Order to
Brave New World is because New World Order has
a connection with this big conspiracy theory
that's really distasteful in real life before
they changed the title I was not familiar with
that conspiracy theory like I actually had to
look it up but once I did read about it I was
like oh yeah it's probably better that they
didn't change the title so even though the title
is changing the main plot like everything about
the movie The themes all that stuff is the same
one of the other big new things that they revealed
too is that Rosa Salazar is playing Diamondback
from the serpent Society I believe she's meant
to be the leader of their group during the film
The Serpent Society has deep ties to Val in the
movie or they're supposed to have deep ties to
Val because she's also called Madame Hydra in
the comics serpent Society is a group that comes
through Hydra there were a couple references to
this during Falcon and Winter Soldier when she was
introducing herself for the first time and joking
about out all the different crazy names that she
had during some of the other scenes we got first
looks at it looks like the serpent Society has
their base on tiamit's body and I believe part
of the idea during the movie is that initially she
hires them through her CIA contacts like she's in
control of the CIA if you're not familiar with
the way the CIA Works inside the United States
government they're mostly concerned with foreign
affairs not Internal Affairs that's mostly the FBI
that deals with internal stuff part of the idea is
that when Thunderbolt Ross becomes U.S president
she starts using her resources that are actually
legit now because Thunderbolt Ross tells her to
use her resources to get all of the resources on
team its body and I believe part of the idea is
that that's where they're going to find adamantium
so I believe she hires the serpent Society on the
DL and things go sideways and Sam Wilson's Captain
America has to deal with it and once he does deal
with the serpent society that paves the way for
Val to create the Thunderbolts in the Thunderbolts
movie like they're waiting on Deck like she hasn't
quite created them yet the events of Captain
America 4 will lead directly into Thunderbolts
that's meant to be the very end of Marvel Phase
5 culminating with Val using the weapons plus
program to create the Sentry played by Steven
Yoon is now been confirmed that he is playing
the MCU Sentry the brand new scenes that just
posted are of a battle that Sam's Captain America
is getting ready to have with the serpent Society
while wearing his brand new super suit everyone
gets new suits in their movies Spider-Man always
gets new suits Iron Man even Steve Rogers Captain
America got new versions of the suit the funny
reason why they said they got rid of Sam's cowl
from the comics though is because they said when
they were making Falcon and Winter Soldier the
cow caused them all kinds of trouble while filming
they had to spend a bunch of money to fix it in
post so they just got rid of it completely to make
it easier for them to film the characters here
he's getting ready to fight might seem familiar
this is Seth Rollins most you know from the WWE I
believe he's playing Cobra or constrictor one of
the bigger members of the serpent Society fighting
with Rosa Salazar's Diamondback character as
denoted by the diamond on her suit they've just
changed her suit from the comics she's fought
Sam Wilson's captain in America before so is Val
continuing to be super Shady working with villains
she kind of implied that during Falcon and Winter
Soldier we're not going to need Captain America
things are going to get real weird real fast
meaning that she's gonna get super Shady real
fast the next scenes we have are actually from
a funeral that they're doing and a lot of people
are wondering whose funeral is this meant to be
the rumor is that she's playing his love interest
in the movie also from the military makes sense
Torres is also back from Falcon and Winter Soldier
he's still Captain America or Falcon however you
want to think about him his sidekick by the events
of this movie it'll be like the progression in the
comics when Anthony Mackey becomes Captain America
Torres becomes the new Falcon with a new set of
wings so like online there's just been a lot of
a lot of stuff about Steve actually some people
some people they think that he's in the secret
base on the moon here's the big thing though they
brought back Liv Tyler as Betty Ross from way back
in The Incredible Hulk movie like she's finally
back there have been rumors about her coming
back in Cameo at some point for a long time now
they haven't confirm earned any kind of crazy
Multiverse Cameo scenes from Edward Norton as his
Bruce Banner Hulk but there are a lot of other
characters from that Incredible Hulk movie that
are back during this as you can see Betty Ross is
dressed in the customary black and U.S funerals if
you look around at the tombstones in the cemetery
where they're at at this funeral there aren't any
big Easter eggs on the Tombstone names but that
doesn't really mean anything necessarily Marvel
will probably alter those Tombstone names in
post-production just to avoid spoilers but here's
the thing this funeral they're at is probably for
Thunderbolt Ross himself there's a new scene of
him on set separate like a completely different
scene wearing a regular dress suit and if you
didn't realize they did recast Harrison Ford as
Thunderbolt Ross William Hurt passed away recently
originally it was going to be him in the movie and
the reason why they wanted to recast him instead
of using a completely different character is
because Thunderbolt Ross's character was so
critical to the plot that they're doing the
overarching plot for all of Marvel phase five like
this whole dark rain era that they're doing in the
MCU because they wanted to turn Thunderbolt Ross
into Red Hulk during this movie and they didn't
want to completely pivot and just turn Val into
Red Hulk like they have other plans for Val entine
Val's other alias in the comics is Madame Hydra
and she's critical to the villain's storyline
during the movie though like there's a lot of
shady stuff going on in the background she's kind
of a villain in the same way that Sharon Carter is
a Villain Like characters that don't actually have
superpowers just work with technology or wield
enormous political influence so what I think
is actually going on in this funeral scene that
they're filming is that Valen Thunderbolt Ross are
pretending like Thunderbolt Ross dies during the
movie and using that as an excuse so the public
will stop thinking about him like it'll be a great
tragedy and they'll use it to their advantage but
they use this to fool all the heroes like Anthony
Mackey's Captain America as well so that everyone
thinks that he's dead and stops worrying about him
and while that's happening Val uses the weapons
plus program and the leader character who's also
back from Incredible Hulk you notice he's green
now like he is in the comics you can see Tim Blake
Nelson getting ready for another scene here his
hands are painted green because they're just doing
the rest of the green for his body and motion
capture his larger head the visual effects so he
doesn't have to wear a giant rubber head around on
set Val is going to use him to turn Thunderbolt
Ross into the Red Hulk because this whole thing
Incredible Hulk was experimenting with the Hulk's
blood but when it comes to all the action like the
big fight scenes you have to remember that he's
going to be motion capture Red Hulk for most of
the movie so they can do all the crazy Hulk versus
Red Hulk Red Hulk versus other characters like red
Hulk vs Captain America fights and it's no big
deal also by the events of the movie Thunderbolt
Ross is supposed to have become U.S president
I believe something's supposed to happen to the
previous U.S president during the secret Invasion
series because secret Invasion led to dark reign
in the comics that's what they're using the
secret Invasion series to set up in the MCU
I believe during the series something's supposed
to happen to that previous U.S president like they
find out that he's secretly a scroll or he winds
up dying or is assassinated in some way according
to Don Cheadle who we see Rhody in all the secret
Invasion trailers by the events of secret Invasion
he's meant to be the right-hand man advisor to
that previous U.S president and once something
happens to that previous president that paves the
way for Thunderbolt Ross to become president and
they'll use him for like a Norman Osborne style
twist at the end of the comic book sacred Invasion
where he winds up taking most of the credit for
getting rid of the bad Scrolls everybody loves
him but he's Thunderbolt Ross so he uses that to
gain more power by becoming the US president and
when that happens he just opens the floodgates
and lets Val do whatever she wants to do all the
Shady stuff that they normally would think was too
crazy to do we'll start getting some more teasers
and trailers later this year of course I'll do
more videos if you have any big questions about
what's going on just leave them in the comments
below the next big thing that's happening will be
the secret Invasion episodes we only have to wait
a couple more weeks for that that'll set up the
dark rain storyline that you'll see them pay off
during Captain America 4. I just posted my review
of The Flash movie you can click here for that
and click here for all my secret Invasion trailer
videos thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!